in the west people are likely to face a
brutal summer because they don't have
enough water the latest government map
shows nearly all of the west is in
drought 95 of california is suffering
severe or extreme drought ben tracy
looks at the unprecedented impact and
the response to keep the region from
going completely dry
wildfires are raging and reservoirs are
draining and it's not even summer yet
we knew climate change would stress our
water supplies
and we've been preparing for it but we
did not know it would happen this fast
for the first time ever officials in
southern california are declaring a
water shortage emergency warning they
only have a little more than half the
water needed to get through the rest of
the year this is real this is serious
this is unprecedented
six million californians will be forced
to limit all outdoor watering to just
once a week but a complete ban is
looming and could happen by september
california's not alone lake mead the
largest reservoir in the nation is so
low they just turned on a new pump to
ensure las vegas can still get water
the problem with climate change is that
it takes all the historical patterns and
kind of shifts them jt reger is a nasa
scientist he says the west is in a
22-year mega drought as climate change
makes it hotter and drier a lot of
people would call this the new abnormal
that's right we're just starting to see
the dominoes fall so it's drier we have
less water in reservoirs then we have
fires and in california there's really
the series of consequences that we
anticipate as the american west tries to
adapt to climate change in real time
for cbs mornings i'm ben tracy in los
angeles